bienvenue à la notice notre tour
d'horizon des jantes et du monde sportif
claude julien mon préféré
or claude claude julié du expliqué après
le match de samedi la disparition
soudaine en deuxième période de josh
henderson
non ce n'était pas un test positif à la
coke vide a assuré l'entraîneur chef du
canadien
un crachin automnal dubaï qui s'est tenu
en français comme comme j'aime
mentionnant qu'il y avait des idées il y
avait des 10 et la grève des symptômes
de grippe dite cas pas juste le mot très
saint nom de georges handerson à des
symptômes de grippe ne croit en toi tu
choisis club veut des idées voici cinq
tombes de flux après seulement une
semaine d'existence dans la ligue
nationale de hockey féminin le toronto 6
fait fureur avec ses vidéos tournées
avant et après ces matches parce que les
joueuses ont décidément un énorme
plaisir à retrouver l'aréna même
l'entraîneuse des gîtes murphy participe
en remplaçant ses discours d'avant match
par une danse bien plus inspirantes mois
moi je peux plus gracieux qui sort je
peux pas être plus gracieuse si mon
maximum
j'aimerais bien voir claude julien
sautier comme ça dans le vestiaire mais
pas sur tous les gourmands
[Musique]
encore un temps gardien après le style
papillon aussi dustin crap
pourquoi est ce que les gardiens
pourraient pas avoir une mitaine dans
chaque main de démolition économique des
vides à transformer tous les méprise en
cônes orange ça a l'air tellement facile
que je comprends pas pourquoi il ne fait
pas ça à chaque présence c'est quoi il
n'y a pas que ses amis ne plus jouer
avec lui
pas d'amis une station de télé c'est
louis annoncé par erreur que le lanceur
adam wainwright avait resigné avec les
blues plutôt que les corps de noces et
il a joué le jeu à fond
[Musique]
on le donne quand même quelques mois
pour parfaire sa technique montréal de
son côté voit s'éloigner la tenue de la
coupe du monde de soccer en 2026 parce
que le gouvernement du québec ne veut
pas allonger 100 millions de dollars
pour nouveau toit sur le stade olympique
selon moi on peut avoir la coupe du
monde sont investis maintenant dans
gamestop qui troquera gérald ce qui est
des autres autant pour ça à 52 ans la
légende de la planche à roulettes tony
hawk a réussi sept cent vingt ans la
quarantaine
il avait déjà réussi interne 1900
donc tous unis voici mon programme pour
les prochaines années
juin 5 40 à 60 ans 1 3 60 à 70 1 180 à
80 et à 90 je veux juste que tu restes
de boutons ce qu'est des partisans de
l'olympique de marseille ont tenté
d'entrer de force dans le centre
d'entraînement de l'équipe lors d'une
manifestation explosé pour dénoncer les
dirigeants de l'équipe et sont
suffisamment colère faudrait surtout pas
leur dire qu'il n'ya jamais eu de jeux
olympiques à marseille et que ça sera
bien meilleur niveau
le club de foot montréal l'impact de
montréal allez l'om c'était pour nous on
vous demande encore une fois de bien
vouloir partager la vidéo si vous aimez
la natif ça nous donne toujours un bon
coup de main je voudrais m'excuser aussi
à tous mes collègues qui vont mal dormir
pour les quatre prochaines années parce
que j'ai gagné le pôle du vendée globe
[Rires]
partager la nature c'est comme applaudir
quand arte a fourni un but et cinq ans